MALE SPEAKER: All
right, thank you
guys for coming to our Guest
Chefs @ Google LAX program.
We're super, super,
super excited
to have chef Dakota Weiss of
NINETHIRTY and The Backyard
here with us today.
And in true "Top Chef" fashion--
I don't know if you guys know
she was a competitor
on "Top Chef"--
she just whisked in like 10 or
15 minutes ago and put all this
stuff together for you guys.
So again, thank you
for joining the demo.
And without further
ado, I'm going
to send it to chef Dakota.
DAKOTA WEISS: Hi guys.
So I wanted to do
something today that
is reminiscent of Thanksgiving,
given that that's coming up.
And I don't about everybody
else, but being a chef,
Thanksgiving's a big
deal, because it's
revolves around food,
which is awesome.
So I created the morning
after Thanksgiving breakfast.
And this is something hopefully
you guys can take home and kind
of-- because everybody's
like, what do you
do with all leftovers?
Everybody's tired of turkey
sandwiches with the cranberry
sauce.
So what I created is a
pumpkin pie smoothie.
And really that's just
an excuse to have pumpkin
pie for breakfast, to be honest.
And it is literally just
the whole pumpkin pie
with some fun ingredients.
And then we're going to make
french toast with cranberry
sauce, with shredded up turkey
meat, and smothered in gravy.
So kind of a play on
chicken and waffles,
a little bit, but a
little more refined.
So let's get started with
the pumpkin pie smoothie.
Does anybody here
not like pumpkin pie?
That's funny.
I am kind of the same way.
I don't like pumpkin pie in
this format, but I love pumpkin.
The texture is
really strange to me.
It's one of those
weird texture things.
So I'm kind of the same.
I wouldn't eat
pumpkin pie like this,
but throw it in a blender
with some yogurt and honey?
We've got a party.
All right, so, we're literally
going to take our pumpkin pie
and throw it straight
into the blender.
I mean, does this already
look good, or what?
It is a little messy.
Yogurt, to make it somewhat
healthy and breakfast-y.
And we're going to
add milk, that's
another part of our
healthy part of it.
Smidge of cinnamon,
let's see-- vanilla.
I like to go two capfuls.
And then I'm going to
add a little bit of honey
to it, just because the crust
of it, I noticed yesterday
in my experimentation phase,
makes it a little bit savory.
And so the honey kind of
sweetens it up a little bit.
And then I'm going to
add a little bit of ice.
And then have the
milk handy, just
in case you need to thin it out.
Because obviously pureeing
a whole pie kind of
makes it a little thick.
Who thinks I can do
this without a lid?
We're going to start
with-- stand back.
So we're going to
keep the milk here.
Give it a little stir.
Little spit, all right.
We're almost there.
Voila, first recipe done.
OK, who wants to try?
All right.
I don't know, do you want
to come up and get it?
Do you want me to
bring it to you?
I don't know how that works.
But it's pie for breakfast.
AUDIENCE: Should have
done this for Halloween.
This is really
the most terrified
I've been at a
cooking demonstration.
Sitting in the front--
AUDIENCE: Scott, sit over there.
DAKOTA WEISS: You're
like, oh, my goodness.
AUDIENCE: Everything we've
been taught not to do.
DAKOTA WEISS: We like to
break rules in the kitchen.
How is it?
Tastes like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAKOTA WEISS: Pumpkin pie.
Well, it absolutely
tastes like pumpkin pie.
For me, it's a texture, though.
If you don't like the flavor
of pumpkin, then yeah,
you're going to be like, meh.
AUDIENCE: Chef,
chef-- [INAUDIBLE].
DAKOTA WEISS:
Vitaprep all the way.
Vitamix, yeah.
I mean, in my opinion,
it's the best.
I mean, you just saw-- it
took an entire pie, crust,
everything, with a little bit of
work with a spoon or a spatula.
I would recommend maybe at home
using a rubber spatula, not
a metal spoon.
But Vitamix, absolutely.
How is it?
All right, cool.
So now we're going to
make our french toast.
So has everybody made
french toast before?
Pretty easy, right?
Start with awesome ingredients,
such as cream, eggs.
And then I add a little
bit of brown sugar.
I don't want to add
too much, because it
is kind of a savory
french toast.
But a little brown
sugar will help
caramelize the french
toast part of it.
I'm going to whisk that up.
I like to use brioche, and I
slice it about an inch thick.
And then you're just going
to put that in the bowl
and let that egg mixture
really soak up into it.
Butter, hot pan.
And basically for the gravy
part and the turkey part,
all I did was-- the
great thing about this
is all this stuff
is already cooked.
So I just took the
gravy, heated it up.
Shredded up the rest,
especially picking off
all that good part
of the turkey that's
left on there, if you didn't eat
it in the middle of the night,
that is.
Shred it all up, throw
it right into the gravy
as the gravy's coming
up to temperature.
And basically you
just kind of make
like a turkey
gravy, more or less.
You can put this in the pan.
When you see this butter
start to foam like that,
that's a good sign
that your pan is ready.
And then the cranberry
sauce, obviously,
is already made as well,
which is super awesome.
Give that a stir.
So I kind of just--
with french toast,
it's really easy to make.
The trickiest thing to me
is when the french toast
is kind of raw in the middle.
That's not super
awesome, in my opinion.
So what I like to do
if it's really, really
thick French toast,
I'll cut it in half
and then sear the insides of it.
I'll show you that
in a second here.
Then we get nice little
brown caramelization.
Has anybody ever had
gravy-smothered french toast
before?
Sound fun or it sounds weird?
I think it sounds fun.
Especially since
being in LA, we've
got Roscoe's
Chicken and Waffles.
It's similar.
So you see we start to
get the little brown color
on the french toast.
It takes a little bit of time,
but patience is a virtue.
Does anybody have any awesome
plans for Thanksgiving?
Going anywhere?
Cooking anything?
No plans?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAKOTA WEISS: That's
always a good thing.
Anybody a football fan?
Don't the Cowboys play on
Thanksgiving every year?
I'm not a huge football fan.
I think it's a big
deal for most people.
And you can see on
the french toast,
we're starting to get that
really yummy brownness,
and that's really crispy.
And the butter from
it adds a really nice
like toasty nuttiness to it.
So once you've got that
on both sides, what
I was talking about earlier
is, kind of just take it out.
And I like to cut it like so.
See how the inside's
kind of raw inside still?
You just kind of slice it,
put it right on like that.
That way you avoid raw
egg in the morning,
because nobody
really likes raw egg.
AUDIENCE: Do you
prefer ceramic knives?
Or is just for small--
DAKOTA WEISS: For
small stuff these
are really kind of fun knives.
Plus they're pink,
and I love pink.
But they're really lightweight.
And when you're
cooking all day long
and you've got a
super heavy knife,
after a while your
arm is just like, ugh.
It's very tiring.
Just depends on what
I'm doing, honestly.
Something like this-- perfect.
So see how we get a nice
cool little caramelization
inside there?
Yum.
I'm just going to
kind of beautifully
place these on our plate.
That one needs to
go a little longer.
And then you've already got
your chicken, sorry chicken,
turkey-- it is
Thanksgiving, right?
In a pot, heated for you.
Cranberry sauce-- I heated
this up a little bit,
just because I think it'll
taste a little better.
But really you're going to
kind of just load it up.
Top like that, and we're going
to add our delicious gravy
mixture.
Voila, breakfast is served.
Does it look good?
I think it's going
to taste delicious.
So I'm going to make some
smaller ones for you guys.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: What
are you guys doing
at the restaurant
for Thanksgiving?
DAKOTA WEISS: At
the restaurant we
do a family-style
Thanksgiving, just
because-- since I
have to work on it,
I want to pretend
like I'm having
a normal Thanksgiving
like most people.
So we have a pretty
traditional Thanksgiving menu
with the turkey.
We're doing a Seckel pear salad,
a sunchoke parsnip bisque.
Let me think what
else we've got.
Pretty much normal,
pumpkin pie, of course.
Pumpkin creme brulee, as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAKOTA WEISS: A pie
besides pumpkin?
I have a favorite that
I make every year.
It's my favorite, since
I'm not a pumpkin pie fan.
I make a buttermilk
rum soaked raisin pie.
And they're really, really easy.
And then I think another great
traditional one is pecan pie.
Those are my two go-tos, since
I'm not a super huge pumpkin
pie person.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Do you
do the pie crust?
Do you make the pie crust?
DAKOTA WEISS: Well, it
depends on if I have the time.
AUDIENCE: Do you make
the crust [INAUDIBLE]?
DAKOTA WEISS: It
just sticks together.
Because you do it
when it's really cold,
and it's kind of
like-- I'm trying
to think something
to relate it to.
It just does.
Because it's like the flour
and the butter and everything
has binded together.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAKOTA WEISS: Yeah,
you can roll it.
I think that's a like super
awesome Martha Stewart trick.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAKOTA WEISS: It does
require patience.
And especially with baking, I
don't have a lot of patience.
And I'm not the best baker.
It's a lot about measuring
everything, weighing everything
out.
And I get a little too antsy and
I want it now, now, now, now,.
I'm not super huge on like,
clearing off the teaspoons.
So it is tricky.
But like she said, the
rolling pin method is great.
But as long as it's cold
and it's made properly.
But if I'm at home usually
I just buy frozen pie crust.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAKOTA WEISS: Exactly, exactly.
Are there any vegetarians?
Because I can make
it minus the turkey.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
tips for the perfect turkey?
Is it buying the right
turkey, or cooking it right?
DAKOTA WEISS: It's still
a little of everything.
For me, the most important thing
about having your turkey come
out moist, which I
think everybody-- that's
kind of their biggest thing,
like it's always so dry--
is to brine it.
You know, put it in a
salt, sugar mixture.
I like to put a
little bit of scotch
in mine, just because it makes
it so much better, and lots
of thyme, lots of garlic.
It's basically just equal
parts sugar and salt to water.
Let it sit overnight and then
take it out and roast it.
I always shove a little
butter under the skin,
because butter makes
everything better.
AUDIENCE: Butter and scotch.
DAKOTA WEISS: Butter
and scotch, right?
What else could you ask for?
AUDIENCE: Bacon.
DAKOTA WEISS: Bacon, good one.
All right, I don't know
if you have-- oh yes,
forks, right there.
Here's the morning after.
I think I made enough.
Please come up and try, or
I could bring it to you.
Whatever's easier.
There's lots, yes-- absolutely.
AUDIENCE: You can eat
this for breakfast
and then a turkey
sandwich for lunch.
DAKOTA WEISS: Probably, yeah.
Does it taste like Thanksgiving?
AUDIENCE: What were the
proportions of [INAUDIBLE] egg?
DAKOTA WEISS: I usually
go almost equal.
And then sometimes if
I'm feeling super saucy,
I'll add a little
extra egg yolk just
to give it more of
a custardy feel.
AUDIENCE: Do you
put the [INAUDIBLE]?
DAKOTA WEISS: You said
Alton Brown said that?
He's a genius.
So I normally listen
to everything he says.
I don't know.
I also don't like
it, though, when
it gets really, really soggy.
And brioche is very
absorbent bread.
So if it gets too
soggy, it literally just
like crumbles to pieces.
And then you've just got, like,
bread pudding so to speak.
But I mean, he's pretty smart.
And most of the time he knows
what he's talking about.
I've not tried that technique.
But I'm going to tonight.
How is it?
AUDIENCE: Delicious.
DAKOTA WEISS: Would
you have that?
It's easy to make
for breakfast, right?
Everybody goes back
to their family
and wake up the next morning
and surprise your whole family.
Look what I did.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DAKOTA WEISS: Bread
pudding, absolutely.
Nothing wrong with
bread pudding.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAKOTA WEISS: If you
don't have plans,
then definitely come to the
W. We've got a fun menu.
We've got a turkey burger
that we're serving out
in our backyard
restaurant in case
you don't want to do the
whole big dinner thing.
But we have everything.
AUDIENCE: Are you
at the [INAUDIBLE]?
DAKOTA WEISS: There's two.
I'm the one in Westwood,
which is on the UCLA campus.
Well, near UCLA campus.
It's kind of tucked
right between now
Wilshire and Sunset.
And we've got a
huge backyard, lots
of outdoor seating with a
tent, given our cold weather.
So, excellent-- thank you guys.